do you own dogecoin you tweeted out that
you owned it dude is that real
yeah i mean like so it's a huge
thing for you uh well okay so the part i
didn't tweet out was that i took gains
along the way
feel like i can rule the world i know i
could be what i want to
i put my all in it like no days off on
the road let's
travel never looking back all right
everyone welcome to the episode do me a
favor
mfmpod.com so that's my first million
but abbreviated so
m f m pod like podcast so mfmpod.com
if you go there right now you're going
to see an inbox uh an email form enter
your email
and each thursday sean's sending out an
email that does a summary of
all the episodes that we've discussed
and or launched that week so
make sure to sign up you'll get a
description of every single episode
along with all the links that we've
mentioned all the cool companies that we
mentioned and also
we're doing a tour so that comes out
soon but
this june we're going to june or we're
going to austin and then miami
and we're going to announce those dates
like that so go to mfnpod.com and sign
up
and you can be notified when all this is
happening and you'll get your weekly
email that discuss the podcast
sean what are we talking about today
today we talk about peak
a testosterone subscription company we
talked about
b-roll which is a small little kind of
bootleg company that i think
could be big could be bigger and uh but
it does have some problems
and then we talked about a couple of
gambling gambling websites gambling
products that i think are cool
zed run which is all the rage right now
people selling digital horses for 20
million dollars
and poly market a place where you can go
bet on
anything so we talked about that as well
and make sure to listen to towards the
end or
i'm not trying to trick you you could
just skip ahead but uh we said
our feelings on today's episode and i
think a lot of people are gonna like
what we had to say but
you might need to listen to the first
bit uh the first half at least
understand the context so give it a
listen
do you guys want to do the intro yeah
let's do the intro
i feel like i kind of up that
episode i don't feel like i did a good
job but
um leave leave this
leave this part in too so i
think it's worth it why do you think it
was a dud
uh sometimes i just look at the clock
and i'm like oh we're halfway
through the episode and i feel like we
uh what have we said so far you know and
then like
that's what that's how i judge it uh
abreu what did you think
yeah i thought it was a b i thought we
spent too much time on things that
weren't ideas
um some of the ideas that we did talk
about were things that we've talked
about before like peak and zed run
um thought b-roll was actually really
cool i'm glad we spent time on that
but overall b all right and you guys
just didn't have the energy
sam you didn't bring the energy today
man is that
great that's crazy how you could tell i
don't feel well at all um
but i didn't think that i was low energy
dude some days i'm just like having
a sluggish day bad day i get on this
call and i just i get your guys energy
that just like helps me get through the
day and
that's funny no i feel horrible i didn't
sleep well i mean i just feel
i do feel sluggish i just didn't i had a
bad night's sleep that's so funny that
that
radiates that sucks i thought you i
thought you were fine
but you usually have one or two moments
in the episode that are like the sam
moment where you like
get really either excited or you think
something's really dumb
and uh yeah so so that didn't happen but
let's talk about some stuff you want to
talk about peak did you invest in peak
i did when uh over the weekend i talked
to him
maybe friday and on the first call i was
like
and i was actually quite skeptical of
this so this will give people the
context
uh this is one of the first ideas that
we've ever discussed as this new scheme
i think literally episode maybe one or
two of when we started doing the
brainstorm sam goes
trt subscription and i was like what
what he's like
uh so i've been taking testosterone trt
is testosterone replacement therapy
i've been taking testosterone and i
think this could be a great business
um because you know if you take it it
helps you
you're gonna keep taking it on a
subscription like you were talking about
why the business might be great
and we were both like dude that's a
great idea why doesn't somebody do this
and obviously people were already doing
it
and so you recently were like hey is
this company peak that i'm investing in
that does that testosterone thing you
should talk to them
and so i did and i went in with honestly
kind of like lukewarm
uh expectations i don't know why like i
i don't know i just didn't like i didn't
know how big it was going to be i didn't
really know like i i
myself i don't take it because i'm like
i had some concerns like is this really
good for you or bad for you blah blah
blah
and then i was totally convinced on the
call the guy was
the guy sod who you introduced me to is
an amazing communicator like
this guy was so good at selling me on
the business
i was like you're gonna sell everybody
your product if you can sell me this
well on your business uh he was a
really really talented guy yeah he he is
talented
it's a it's a really it i think it's a
pretty safe bet
is what i think i think it's i think
it's a safe bet but
i there so basically trt is
uh i believe it you know i should know i
put it in my body but
it's i believe it's synthetic
testosterone and
you can put it in via like you can rub
it on your body we should explain the
problem right which is that yeah
males uh you know as you age in general
your testosterone levels go down right
so in your 20s you're the stallion and
then by the time you're in your 40s
your testosterone levels are you know i
don't know
multiples less than they were in your
20s okay that's just nature taking
you know that's father time okay but
there's also like other issues which is
that
today a guy in his 20s and 30s has the
testosterone levels
of like a 70 year old man 50 years ago
or something crazy like there's there's
some stats
there's a lot of reasons to why why
that's the case although
uh doctors and scientists they're like
well we don't exactly really know but
it could possibly be that we live like
pretty soft lives like there's not that
much fear
or like compared to like we don't have a
death
threat on a regular basis or a dying of
different diseases although
maybe that's different the last two
years we um we um
drink plastic we or we drink out of
plastic what else
did they say we we smoke less which a
lot of people think nicotine
and uh just testosterone levels are are
correlated uh and there's a variety of
other reasons but basically
the average person's t level the average
per the average boy
man they're the 25 year old is like that
of like a 56 year old
yadda yadda and what that means is
a lot of guys think well testosterone
okay so you're just gonna have big
muscles and look good naked
that's kind of actually kind of like a
secondary thing the first thing is that
you actually
become incredibly depressed and like
bummed and you just don't feel
like i call it like aggressiveness but
it's not really like i want to fight you
aggressiveness it's like i can
i'm like a little bit more confident and
i have a purpose
anyway um i got tested for this and i
had a low t and i tried a lot of
different solutions so i tried this
company
it's pretty great i i think it's i think
it's a i think it could be pretty cool i
think
they're doing pretty big numbers already
we'll see if they can pull it off i
think
a company like a testosterone business
this is one of those companies i think
sean you said it one day where you're
like there's a bunch of different risks
here there's technological risk like can
you actually build it
there's market risk like does the market
actually want this um in this case
those two things aren't risks the third
risk is operational excellence
uh are you competent enough to pull this
off and that's the risk that they have
and i actually think that's a that's a
pretty easy risk because that's a
commodity i mean there there's
there if you overpay a handful of uber
employees they're gonna figure out the
problem
yeah you go find the guy who opened up
uber's like atlanta
business and you're like yeah i need uh
you you're you are an operational person
i need you to come here and solve this
problem
by the way i think i've invested in four
companies and like on the founding team
of each of them was like
i opened up uber in chat i ran uber's
canada business i went there first to
open it
i became the gm or like there's an uber
competitor uber for flowers right bloom
that
i invested in the guy who like ran that
because it's like these guys have
operational excellence they just need to
find a good market
that uh really wants a product so i
think you're right that the market does
want this but there is
you know an education step that has to
be done product yeah they have almost
zero
products um but it really is about
regulation and
operational excellence so do they have
regulatory risks
and do they have operational excellence
because you have to properly handle it
right the flow
is they don't just give testosterone to
anybody you take a test
so you at home finger prick you send the
blood to the lab the lab
you know it gets reviewed by a doctor
and the doctor says yeah your levels are
great or your levels are low
and if your levels are low we can offer
you a prescription if you want
and um and then when you get the
prescription they need to keep measuring
over time
to see if your levels are improving or
not and that sort of thing and so
there's a big kind of like time lag it's
not just like
you know buying a thing off amazon or
two days later it's at your house and
there's no risk in
in playing with that toy it's like no
there's risks this is actual medical
it's a medical it's a digital medical
workflow and those are new
so like all of the telehealth um
products are like this
hymns and rho are probably the most
successful versions of these
where they took viagra and they said
okay how do we
market to people who might have erectile
dysfunction how do we get them a
prescription
how do we so how do we pair a person on
facebook who sees our ad
to a doctor who can prescribe them you
know
that they had that they had diagnosed
them with erectile dysfunction and
prescribed them a medicine
and how do we create the generic version
of viagra how do we take this product
and how do we sell it and then how do we
do that whole thing profitably right
so similar similar mindset those have
become multi-billion dollar companies
and i think that there's more to come in
that vein i've invested in a couple peak
being the latest but
yeah i think this is great and you like
you said
the thing i would have been worried
about was twofold one
uh does this really work and what are
the side effects and as he was talking
me through it i was like okay well
you're very convincing but obviously
you're somewhat biased right here like
the owner of this company uh
but he started as a user of the product
so so i think it is somewhat organic
um but i was like okay that sounds good
i'm gonna do some independent research
and i'll figure this out for myself too
the second thing was i didn't like the
idea of injecting myself in the butt
or i don't know where do you where you
interest yourself the thigh i put it in
my thigh and it doesn't hurt at all
i do it two days a week and why don't
you take the gummy
or like the cream that seems like like a
gummy seems way better than a shot
i got used to it and i didn't want to
deviate uh
i had a provider that only did the shot
and i just was like yeah i'm used to it
it also like feels like it's going to
work better i don't actually know if it
does and
i asked him this i go i go
he said he has all three and i go why
would anybody choose the shot
he goes actually if you look in
popularity our shot is the most popular
and the second is this and the third is
this and i said is that because it's
more effective
and he goes no it's not more effective
in fact the cream is the most effective
but uh but people believe there's a
there's a perception that the shot oh
this is i'm doing the real thing i'm
getting the full effect of this
and i thought that's funny how that like
perception is reality
yeah so i like it but i've been doing it
for a while and
um this isn't like a peak uh commercial
we could and so we'll
just be explicit about this shawn and i
both have a financial incentive in this
company we are both
investors of this company but uh it's
sick we've been talking about trt for a
while
i'm a fan and uh i've been taking it now
for two or three years
um it changed my body i didn't take it
from my body but it changed
i think they'll be at 100 million in
sales in the next three years that's my
my prediction my bet
yeah i believe that the question is who
buys it and um
i don't know yet i mean it's a pretty
taboo thing so they got to fight some
taboo
uh stuff but uh yeah we'll see i mean
because people when they say they're
like oh you're taking steroids
and i joke i'll be like yeah i take
steroids it's not actually steroids
right it's not
an anabolic steroid steroid um
but they do they've got some they've got
a little bit of culture uphill battle to
fight but i think
people are going to be open-minded to
this actually far more than i ever
thought i know a lot of people who take
trt and i was shocked that
uh that that many people do i thought i
was gonna be the only one
especially because joe brogan aka the
male oprah
does it and vouchers for it i think that
goes a big way like that guy has like a
pretty massive
mainstream following and uh when he
normalizes something
uh it's just a matter of time you know
first his die-hards will go do it
and then the other people get curious
and start to check it out and eventually
as it gets more popular people will
remember
that joe vouch for joe does it so
you know i think that goes a long way
just like oprah had a big effect on a
lot of businesses i think
a person of joe rogan's magnitude is
actually not just any other influencer
do you want to talk about some of these
ideas that you have you've got some
amazing ideas do you want to talk about
zed
that's crazy let's talk about zed okay
so we both
uh we mentioned zed on the pod before
why don't you explain what it is
and then no you do it it's so it's this
is like perfect for you this is like a
you this is like a sean company
okay it's it's really simple zed is a uh
it's digital horse racing so if you've
ever been to a horse racing track
super fun you know saturday sunday
experience you go to a track there's a
bunch of horses you don't know anything
about horse racing that you don't know
anything about the strategy
you look at the sheep you know what do
you do at a horse racing event you sort
of drink and you bet
and um and so the betting part is
there's eight horses that are about to
run
you don't know anything about any horses
you look at the names and they all got
funny names like you know
um you know mother's last hope or
something like that and then you're like
you know what i think mother's last hope
might win i'm gonna bet 50 bucks on
mother's last hope
90 on uh you know uh sam park ponytail
and then the last one
you know is like whatever me lucky
charms and so you bet on three horses
out of the eight
the horses run across you're cheering
like crazy you just want your horses to
win they maybe they do they maybe they
don't
and uh and whatever it's a good time and
so horse racing is
almost like the purest form of gambling
because you really don't
there's really no strategy that you
don't need any skill or strategy
but you're safe because really the other
people also don't have any skill or
strategy
so it's not like a poker table where if
you don't know what you're doing you'll
get taken advantage of
um horse racing is very simple in that
way so what zed did was
they brought that online okay well
that's that seems kind of niche
the smart thing was they brought it
online in the crypto format so the way
it works is
um it is a crypto project it is an nft
project which we talked about before
so you go on zed and you can buy a horse
so you can uh you can buy a horse or you
can breed two horses together
and um and so you'll have a horse and
then you can race your horse and then
your horse can win for
you or he can lose for you it's sort of
like a little tamagotchi pet of yours
and um and every horse has like these
characteristics so
there's like a probability when you
breed your horse or when you buy your
horse
there's like a probability it's gonna be
like a small fraction of chance it's
going to be the lebron james of horses
it's so athletic it's just going to win
every race and then there's a
probability it's going to be average or
below average
and so there's a gambling aspect just in
the breeding and buying of horses
not just the races themselves and so
people are going on there they're cold
they're buying and collecting horses
like their pokemon
and they race them against each other
and they win money and these guys are
crushing it so
yeah so this what sean just said so the
url is
zed dot run so z e d dot run
well he just described it sounds kind of
silly
and looks like it is silly i guess like
oh i guess gambling is silly but
whatever it's fun
and and the artwork is cool and what he
just sounds sounds like a small idea
but their numbers are a stop are
astonishing so go ahead what are the
numbers
they uh they sell horses like in a in a
batch so it'll be like
you know in june they'll do like a drop
of new horses that you can go buy
and so they just did a drop a few days
two days ago i think three days ago
so they did a drop and um it was 18
million
in digital horse sales so they sold 18
million dollars of
digital horses to 2400 buyers
uh the top spender paid about eight
hundred thousand dollars
and the top hundred spenders spent eight
point three million dollars
and um and so what's up what's happening
here under the hood is that
there's a group of people who are
investors and they believe in nfts
they love to gamble and one one of my
friends is those guys uh
well joe we'll just say joe he he spent
six figures on it
that's amazing we're gonna have one of
the biggest whales on the pod i forgot
to tell you this the uh one of the
biggest whales in this whole space in
the nft space reached out and he has a
crazy story and he's like i'd love to
come tell the story on your pod so
so we should have him on he will go in
more in depth with him there but
my understanding is that there's these
people that were really big into daily
fantasy like they played draftkings fan
duel
and these were the whales there and then
you know they were doing daily fantasy
for a while
and then top shot came out nba top shot
and they went heavy into top shot they
bought a bunch of top shot things
they were buying and selling from each
other and i was driving up the prices
and um and they had these huge top shot
collections and now topshop was worth a
lot more money and they did well there
and then they said all right great
what's the next top shot and they went
to
zed run and zed run is the next top shot
and so so
that's what they're doing 18 million
where do the proceeds go
so i think it goes to zed i don't think
there's anybody else to go to here so
i think zed basically mints the horses
and uh
and they they buy them so that zed gets
the sort of initial sale
and then from there um you know if i
sell my horse to you
i can i get the proceeds of that sale
then from from there there's maybe some
transaction fees so i think that's it i
don't think there's any other
like i don't think there's miners and
other stuff involved but
that could be wrong who puts up the pr
and then when you buy your horse and
then what's the likelihood that your
horse is going to win a race
is is it do they establish you basically
when you're buying a horse you're buying
you that probability that it's going to
win i'm i'm out of my peg right here i
don't know exactly how the horse
racing probabilities work you know how
does the slot machine work i'm not
exactly sure i just know i pull the
lever and
look for looking for cherries so so it's
crazy so let me tell you
i'll give you some inside baseball here
sean talked about
told me about this uh 60 days ago maybe
uh your friend narendra told us about it
told both of us about it
yes and you brought up a podcast and
this was was this 60 days ago maybe two
months ago
and you guys described it and i was like
this is silly but
shawn's been pretty spot on with some of
this stuff narendra has been spot on as
well
he was early on clubhouse even you know
he he he sees
and i contacted the founders of zeb
and i got him on the phone and i spent
like an hour talking to him
and they're raising money and i was like
i'm in they're gonna let me invest
and they took a week and they said no we
don't have either
i did it it was a vague either like they
don't have room
or they're not sure if they're gonna
raise um regardless well that's cool
um but it's pretty nuts the amount of
interest that they've been getting
and the founders were really cool guys
and i was devastated i didn't get you
can get in you guys are listening
call me um but it's it's pretty crazy
like how much interest that this company
is getting yeah exactly
um and so so you know i was i almost
bought a ten thousand dollar digital
horse over the weekend
because uh i wanted to get in before
this drop and i just got busy with
mother's day stuff and then didn't get
around to it but
i think you know i don't know if there's
a good investment or bad investment i
would
my personal opinion is that this is
going to have a hype cycle
and the price is going to go up it's
going to be like oh my god there's
you know this company's done 300 300
million dollars
of digital horse sales and then you know
400 days from now
um we're going to be like remember zed
run that was that was a fun
four weeks kind of like big clout
kind of like big clout kind of like top
shot kind of like clubhouse right like
this is not uncommon and it's not really
even a knock on them like look they did
better than 99 percent of startups that
don't get a hype cycle but
um i don't see how much longevity there
is here
because it's the trick is when the
primary value is speculation
then it's hard for something to sustain
and in here it's like primary value
number one is speculation i'm gonna get
this horse i'm gonna sell it for more
primary value two is a game and both
games and speculation
uh you know sort of uh fade over time
um with everything except for bitcoin
because for bitcoin
the speculation is actually what makes
it valuable um
you know people speculate that the price
will go higher the higher the price goes
the more it actually is a store of value
so
the speculation actually creates the
product whereas that's not the case
for zit do you ever ask yourself
how are we going to build or how you
know how
individually how do we make stuff on the
internet that can actually last
20 30 40 50 years because you think of
the things that
are in the top uh 50 companies right now
most of them i bet that are tech based
are launched inside the last 15 how's
google 20 years old
um ish yeah
year 2000 maybe or 96 so 25 yeah
everything's so new and changes so
rapidly do you ever ask yourself how are
you going to create something that can
last a long time or you not care about
that
i don't really care about that what i do
care about i guess like my view is that
you've got to go on
either end of the spectrum either you
try to build something that's going to
be really defensible and valuable
and really what what i mean so for me
it's not about something
lasting over time it's this one theory
which is
um does it have a positive flywheel
which means
the more people who use it and the
longer it's around does it become more
and more valuable there's some something
called the law of increasing returns
and so i want to be in a business that's
like that might be hard to get
turning explain that what does that mean
yeah so like an example of it
is as many but let's say amazon or
amazon is the classic example of this so
what makes a shopping store
valuable a store is valuable if it has
large selection low prices and fast
delivery
so with amazon for every single customer
that comes on for every single product
that they add to it
they're increasing the variety
available to that customer because they
have so many customers they can offer
the lowest prices
and because they have so many customers
and so much uh like
um built up you know sort of supply
chain
infrastructure to behind their thing
they can offer the fastest delivery and
so
for them every new customer or every new
merchant
is just like it's kind of like you used
to say with the hustle every email is a
win
you know we're a pirate ship and every
email subscriber is a little wind in our
sales
it's that but basically it makes it
better for everybody else the classic
example of this is facebook right so
every
person who joins facebook makes facebook
more valuable to all the other people on
facebook
and so in the beginning when facebook
has zero people on it it's not very
valuable to anybody even the first 10
people is not very valuable to anybody
but once it gets every additional person
the thing gets more defensible over time
it gets more valuable to its existing
customers which makes it harder for
anybody to compete
and they don't have to do a new thing
they don't have to come up with a new
idea
or a new business line like all they had
to do was just get more people using it
because the people were the value
um and uber same thing every additional
driver on the road
um makes the the vet the service more
valuable to everybody because you get
faster pick up times
and faster pickup times means more
people will take rides more people take
rides means more dollars available for
drivers
which means more drivers on the road
which means faster pickup times again
right so like
that's the law of increasing returns so
so that's what you really want is what's
called a positive flywheel so i care
about that a lot
because business is really hard anyways
um
but when you don't have that you're just
always working
harder and harder to get more whereas
with those businesses you work
extremely hard at the beginning to get
it going but then momentum starts to be
on your side and i like that um i
and i used to be and i and i have to
fight this you and i are
or i don't know if you are but i would i
you might be we're
where i like to take shortcuts when i
first start stuff or at least i like i'm
used to just
get going here yeah yeah like let me
like because i was always really good
i'm like i can blunt i can blunt
i can i can force you know brute force
this uh
people always just say like um well
you know if you want to chop down a tree
you should spend most of your time
sharpening your axe i'm like that
give me a sledgehammer hammer i'm going
to start banging and by the time you're
done with your sharpening i'm going to
knock it out i'll be halfway through
yeah
yeah i'm like just get out the way i'm
going to use strength and just and just
you know force a will and i'm going to
get it done and that
that actually is super effective a lot
of times but
it's incredibly harmful some of the time
because i have taken
shortcuts where i'm like man had i done
in this this way and just slowed down
and done it the right way i would have
been i would have paid huge dividends
eight months ten months 14 months later
right i wish i would have done that
and when i hear these stories um i
definitely
think like is definitely the right way
you have to put faith that you are going
to be
happier two years from now than you are
if you do this one way even though it
sucks now
yeah so the important thing is to
recognize
the companies that are businesses that
don't have this advantage so let's take
e-commerce
e-commerce is actually quite easy to get
going um
right like you you you don't even have
to have a product you can drop ship
or you just start doing you know you can
do a thousand dollars of ads and make
two thousand dollars of revenue like
great you're in the game it wasn't that
hard to get started you didn't need a
license you didn't need
uh anything to get going maybe some
initial inventory that's kind of like
the biggest barrier
um but ecommerce doesn't ever get this
law of
increasing returns uh i i don't think so
at least
or it's minimal at best which is that
you know if you're at one million
dollars in e-commerce sales
getting to two million um you know
you're gonna have to do more work
you don't get less work over time so you
have to keep manufacturing the product
uh whatever you did last year you know
doesn't really behoove you doesn't
really benefit your
your growth uh you keep having to spend
money on advertising and marketing it
doesn't get cheaper over time it gets
more expensive the bigger you try to
scale it
and so those have you know sort of
almost negative
negative effects over time at the very
minimum it's neutral
and so um so yeah basically i'm just
trying to describe kind of like a
network effect or a flywheel style
business where um
how is it that when you um if you draw
an arrow between
all the different parts of your business
i get customers they do
x because of x y happens because of y i
get more customers
that's what you want the circle has to
connect and if the circle connects
it doesn't matter that if it's hard to
get off the ground once you do it
it's gonna like start spinning faster
and faster and get more and more
valuable over time
that's how you get a long lasting
company that's one way the other way
the other thing i think about is the
exact opposite what's something that
super just super disposable
yeah this arbitrage opportunity may not
be around forever but it's here now
and so when i look at opportunities i
look at one of
i try to go like on one end of the
spectrum or the other when i'm
being smart and then sometimes i'm not
being smart and i go in the middle and i
i hate my life after that and i actually
think that it's important to acknowledge
that there's room for that second one
which is everyone says like
or myself as well i'll look at something
like that and i'll say oh this is like a
get rich quick thing this is just some
stupid
meaningless arbitrage and the answer is
yeah it is right exploit it it exists
have we talked about b-roll we haven't
talked about it before okay so b-roll is
a website
that is not very well known but it's
useful in the e-commerce world so what
is this
so the one of the most effective forms
of advertising
is what's called um ugc user generated
content uh why does this work well
most people are advertising on platforms
like uh facebook or instagram
or you know snapchat pinterest places
like that
and what are you competing with you're
not actually you're not competing with
other advertisers
you're competing against the feed you're
competing against the scroll
if somebody's gonna scroll right by your
ad to the next piece of like
entertaining content right because
you're
it's you're here trying to sell a
product and the next person is trying to
make the person laugh or click the like
button and then keep scrolling so
you know you're competing against a meme
you're competing against an influencer
you're completing against like
you know some model in her bikini on
instagram so how is your ad going to
compete in that that environment
well turns out the best way to compete
is actually not not to stand out but
to blend in to look like instagram
content well how do you do that
so what people started doing was they
were paying started paying influencers
how do i get the kardashians
you know it's like that brand sugar bear
hair they went and they paid the
kardashians
you know silly money to post a picture
with themselves with the little blue
gummy bear in their teeth
in their mouth basically they're holding
it they're like biting down on it and
they took a picture
doing that while holding the bottle of
sugar bear hair right and so they go and
you pay a lot of money for influencers
to do things
and influencers are kind of hard to deal
with they're divas they have managers
and um
you know and this is uh b-roll dot io
d-e-b-e-e-r-o-l-l
dot io b-roll dot io and so what does
b-roll do all right b-roll
basically says hey let's give we will
get you
content that looks like a person on
instagram just using your product it
looks like
someone just posting a review uh you
know a video review where they say
you know i bought this hat uh found this
hat i really love it
here's why uh you know i have this
problem with the sun getting in my eyes
so this hat is amazing for xyz reasons
or they'll be like
you guys i just got my package from
blah blah in the mail i'm so excited to
open it i've been waiting for weeks for
this thing
and it's like what is this uh who is
this like you know
who's this person what have they been
waiting weeks for and then they open it
up and they're like
great here's this eye wrinkle cream and
you know it's gonna be so good
i'm gonna try it on blah blah then make
this video out of it and so
b-roll is basically a way to push a
button
and get a bunch of average
looking people to create the content
that fits your story that you want so
you almost write a little script a
little storyboard where you say
first say that you got the package in
the mail and you're so excited
second open it up while you're in your
bathroom and
show your face in the mirror before
third put the cream on
then fourth uh you know do your makeup
do your hair put
improve the lighting and then show how
much better you look now that you put
our cream on and then say
guys you gotta try it i want you you
guys gotta if you guys follow me you
guys gotta try this
so how did how do they make money they
take a cut so what they've done is they
went and got
all the like wannabe influencers of the
world micro influencers this is like you
know
some mom in florida who wants to make 40
50 bucks
for uh for making a video while she's at
home like while her kid naps
or it's like you know some girl in
college who's in her dorm room and wants
to make you know
100 this month to pay for whatever
you know a manicure at a pedicure and
what they get is they get your product
for free
and then maybe they get a little bit of
cash and in return what you get
is content for your ads that looks like
real human beings making content
because it is real human beings making
content for you is it a big business
it's a good business i don't know it's
not a big business yet
but i think this could be a big mistake
it's sort of criminally under-marketed
right
me explaining this is probably the best
marketing they've had
right and ironically this is actually
like a b-roll right like if they i know
if they're gonna use this did you see uh
there's an app called parcast i think
something like that uh no it's not cool
i forget what it is oh pinata
and they're using your your voice and me
like commenting as an ad i got i got
i kind of got angry at them so uh what's
what's this company's called beehive
i talked to the guy who who owns it i
actually would like to buy a business
like this i think this is a
really good this is a business that can
make
i don't know it can make a lot of money
so here's what i relate this to
there's um there's a business called
user testing which we've talked about
on here i like user testing user testing
did the same thing they activated the
stay-at-home mom workforce
which is there's a whole bunch of people
that are staying at home they want a
little bit of side income
they don't want to have like specific
skills like you know some
coding or designing or something like
that and they just want to make a little
bit of money they'll they're willing to
basically trade
half an hour or an hour of their time
for 10 15 bucks
and uh they have flexibility they do it
when they want and they don't do it when
they don't want it
and so what user testing is is they
basically matched up that mommy
at home workforce with companies that
wanted
feedback on their website so go to my
website try to do x y and z
and record yourself while you do it and
if you get confused i want to see that
so i can go improve my design
and user testing has become a very large
company hundreds of millions in revenue
and we'll go publix you know probably in
the next 12 to 24 months is my guess
and so user testing became a large
company multi-billion dollar company
doing that i think this activates the
stay-at-home work workforce in a
different way which is to say
hey do a review or a testimony of my
product that i can put on my website or
in my marketing
right um what what why wait for why pay
i overpay for influencers
or wait for customers to like take the
time to do this i'll pay you i'll give
you some free product i'll pay you a
little chump change
to create a testimonial or a review or
create whatever you know a little
little short video clip because that's
the what i need to be
advertising on tick tock or anywhere
else great
can i explain to you what i would do if
i wanted to make money off this yeah
i used to have like a little like ecom
things
and i would go to i hate admitting this
because frankly i don't think it was a
good idea
but i would go to fiverr.com and i would
write a script and i would pay someone
five to a hundred dollars to record them
as a testimonial really it wasn't even
that good because they make it look too
professional
yeah yeah it was a testimonial
nonetheless
now i have no idea if this is what
what's it called b-roll i have no idea
if this is what they did but basically
what they're doing is
they're just taking a very specific
niche of fiverr fiverr.com is like
probably the leader in this space it's a
publicly traded company
it's um the whole shtick was five dollar
things that you could do now
uh like you can draw a logo or make a
video a 30 second video and people would
game it i use fiverr.com to
get ten thousand twitter followers and
it
automatically looks like ten thousand
twitter followers would make me look
legit yada yada people use it for scams
what i would do is i'm looking at
fiverr's annual report and they'll
actually tell you
more likely than not what some of the
fastest growing categories are
and what the fastest and most popular
services are or you could just go
straight to fiverr.com and do like
ranked by popularity
and i would just rinse and repeat and i
would look at what be
role did and i would look at which
category is the most popular and i would
create a website
just for that and i think you could
probably build a pretty good business
doing that
we should we should do that we should go
into we should do a dive into fiverr's
um you know like public reports and
let's see what we find because fiverr is
a pretty
interesting business we could do fiverr
and uh maybe like
upwork or whoever i'm gonna show you oh
you can't see my screen huh like you
could do
you could do like like all right i'm
just on fiverr.com like
fiverr but only focusing on voiceovers
so it's like for for five hundred
dollars we'll read whatever you want
for a 60-second thing and i sound like
this voiceover i sound like a movie guy
or you can get this other person
uh who sounds like a commercial lady
from a credit card commercial yada yada
yada yada
yeah or you could do you can do like i'm
gonna send you
a screenshot of the uh of the like the
storyboard
that i submitted um to to use this thing
and uh i mean it's the design looks like
a little bit crazy
but uh but it is pretty cool you'll see
like how this works and i think i think
it makes it very real in your mind like
um how how powerful this would be it's
like uh
so for example if you're an e-commerce
store right now or an e-commerce owner
which is
oh there's a lot of these right shopify
has exploded in popularity
and you you book a photo you book a
professional photographer
you go to a studio and you you go look
at all your favorite brands lululemon
nike
gap whoever right and you say we want to
make commercials like them we want to
have our photos like them
that's the way this should work we want
beautiful
clean you know like perfect lighting
cute models
wearing our stuff smiling and holding
hands and you go put that on facebook
and then next to it you take out your
iphone and you record your face and
you're
you're basically set you basically are
holding up your product in shitty
lighting in your bathroom and you go
guys i just got this you know whatever
lip gloss
and um i don't know why i picked lip
gloss like i i wouldn't even know the
first thing about what to say
sorry let's pick a different one guys
just got this hair product for my
men's long hair that i have um i don't
know about you guys but i wake up in the
morning it looks like this
and then what i do is i just squeeze
this on put this in my hair and bam
i look fantastic and um you know
whatever
even less salesy than that it's just
like guys it looks so good except for
this little part here but i gotta work
on that anyways
you guys get the idea that ad will
kick ass compared to the studio
photographer official
um high quality um uh you know
professionally done
have you even seen that the commercials
on tv people are doing this now too
yeah because they saw because before you
do it measure tv well enough right
tv was hard to measure you couldn't
figure out what works and what doesn't
now you throw both ads on facebook you
throw a thousand ads on facebook and
you'll see
this one gets the most clicks this one
gets the longest views this one
results in highest number purchases so
then they probably did that
spent 100 million dollars on facebook
and said this is the best way to
communicate our product to our customers
now hey tv guy roll this instead
and then they're like are you sure this
looks like it's like no no trust me
this works
and so this lifestyle type of content or
user generated
style of content works so well so then
the question is
you're basically feeding into facebook's
ad engine so this looks like a small
business right it even sounds like a
small business b-roll
who you know like b-e-e like a little
bumble bee the website looks like
um you know how much revenue do you
think they make
i think they're probably doing a couple
million one or two million a year as my
guess
and uh i think that this could easily be
you know nine-figure business
why because you're taking a subset
of the facebook ad engine right facebook
people are spending billions and
billions of dollars on facebook
advertising
if you have a way for them to create
more ad creative that converts better
at scale without hiring their own people
and doing this stuff in-house
people are going to take you up on that
bargain but you'd have to like
you know basically market yourself as
well you'd have to go and figure out how
to get them all to use you
you know what would be kind of cool i'm
just thinking about this is
we talk about so many things that i
would love to do i'm like oh this just
seems exciting
and a lot of people think that way we
should do an episode one day or make a
list of
where we list out the type of headaches
uh that each business comes with
so i think the issue is that we make
things sound easy and in some regard
they are
they're really simple but they have
issues that everything has issues so
like with media the issues is you have
to deal with people personnel
um because it's a your people make your
stuff with e-comm you have to deal with
uh
like the shipping and logistics uh you
have to what do you have to deal with
cash flow issues
um whatever which is the whole supply
chain yeah supply chain stuff with b2b
software
you have to deal with enterprise sales
yeah enterprise sales
and you also have to deal with like it
can feel like it is a little slow
sometimes like it could be a slog um
like there's issues for everything
i would love to hear like what the
headaches are for this
and some of the other stuff that we talk
about so like what are the issues with
this
um probably maybe people uh because
you're dealing with something
it's quality control so the biggest
issue is i'm an advertiser you did all
the hard work to convince me to
start to try using b-roll to get some
videos made
i put up my brief well i kind of wrote
it in kind of a shitty way because i
don't know how to do this
right i wrote my script my script kind
of sucks it was unclear it was
open-ended blah blah blah
that goes to some again some some person
in tennessee who's just doing this for
fun on the weekends to make a little
side cache
they half read the thing they record the
thing but there's like
background noise you know behind them to
the point where you can't hear what
they're saying
or they didn't follow the prompt the
client really said start the video
holding up our product
and uh the person just didn't do that
and um now the video's in
the client expects to get the video they
wanted the the video creator
expects to um get paid
and nobody's happy the client didn't
like the video and
the creator said i did the work what's
up and you're in the middle and you're
now having to
figure out how am i gonna ensure quality
so that my advertisers don't get fed up
and leave
um throughout this process this is the
problem for user testing as well
user testing has a whole fleet of humans
and robotics
to make sure that the tests that get
submitted are gonna make the client
happy
and the client's not gonna say hey i
wanna refund this this person didn't
even follow our directions
or you know they they didn't speak they
just they just clicked they didn't even
give their thoughts out loud
right so like we can't i don't want to
pay 15 bucks for this test i didn't get
what i wanted
and you still owe the guy 15 bucks
because they did the work and if you if
you don't pay either one they're gonna
leave the platform if you don't give you
the one what they want they leave the
platform now you have a churn problem
so quality assurance is the number one
issue with a marketplace like this
in addition to the normal headaches of
going and getting people to
you know join your platform of yeah i
i just want like uh i want like a glass
door for different business ideas like
uh
what what where's the downside because
everything has it just tell me what the
downside is what i got to deal with
um do you want to do one more or no yeah
let's do one more uh because i feel like
i was long-winded
and not that interesting today so i'm
gonna try to make up for it all right uh
let's do one
um okay this is cool poly market have
you seen poly market
no tell me all right i'm gonna i'm gonna
screenshot
what um what i do on this thing so poly
market is a
betting network it's a place to bet on
the future
so you can bet on anything so so if you
go back on your beliefs is the uh the
name is
it's called or the phrase is bet on your
beliefs the the
trademark so it's similar to any betting
platform like oh
i can go bet will the lakers win tonight
are they going to lose right
but you bet on different type of stuff
so here's the top bets right now
uh number one will dogecoin reach one
dollar at any point before june 15 2021
will andrew yang win the democratic
primary of new york city in 2021
and so let's take that andrew yang one
by the way really quick
do you own dogecoin you tweeted out that
you owned it dude is that real
yeah i mean like so it's a huge
thing for you uh well okay so the part i
didn't tweet out was that i took gains
along the way so i bought
uh i bought a million doge at three
cents
and uh so that would be you know i would
have made i don't know like
half a million to a million dollars or
something like that if i just held the
whole thing
but i sold at eight i sold that 15 i
sold at 30 i sold that
so now i still have a slug of it left
uh and i'm just letting that ride at uh
it's at like 50 cents now or something
like that
yeah only tweet the good stuff sorry go
ahead yeah okay so
so um so anyways this so so you could
bet on something so like there was there
was a bet or there's a bet right now
will new york city be fully reopened by
july 1.
and then there's a price on yeah it's
all simple yes and no
so if you just look at this site it'll
show you that 60 grand has been bet on
this bet
and most people are betting no so out of
100 of people who bet
73 said no and 27 said yes
and so when you go bet you get better
odds like if i'm betting the yes side
and only 27
people have said yes i get paid more if
that ends up being correct
if i'm if you take one of these other
bets like oh you know we'll both like
this one i bet this one
which is will floyd mayweather beat
logan paul in their boxing upcoming
boxing match
to me this is like a hundred percent
probability that
if the fight happens floyd mayweather is
going to beat logan paul yeah but on
here uh
you know it's 94 you get 94 cents
basically it's 94
think yes and there's six percent if you
bet the other side if you bet logan
paul's gonna win
and so to me that's free money that's
gonna happen in one month right and so i
can make like a six percent
return on my money this month just by
putting it into that bet
well no uh so i put in 10 grand and if
he wins i make
uh 10 161 no that's only a 1.6
well so the problem is so that's the
thing it's uh there's slippage
if you bet uh more so there's only been
six thousand dollars bet into this bet
so if you bet ten grand you would have
moved the market right so
put in a hundred dollars and you can see
what your what your return is um and so
for the bigger the more popular bets
you can bet 10 grand and it's not going
to move the market right the andrew yang
one has 260 grand in
so your 10k is not really going to move
the prices that much
that's interesting sorry i'm gonna bet
on this floyd one by the way floyd's
gonna just
it won't get me close of course it's not
even is that even a question to me
anyway so there's a bunch of these
things that are like this but i think
this is really cool
it's a really cool product it's a it's a
predict people have been talking about
these prediction markets and crypto for
a while and this is a crypto
based thing so that the problem is
created this
um but just like i don't know some group
some team of people in the crypto world
and so what they say is if you see at
the bottom there's a disclaimer poly
market is only for informational
educational purposes we do not custody
your money
we do not take profits we don't host
these bets themselves so what they say
is
there's a betting protocol
bets get made on there and this is just
a website displaying the bets and
letting you like bet into those markets
or
bed into those bed into the protocol or
not and so
these bets are all made on the ethereum
blockchain so you
um like the whole bet is made there and
then they have a system for validation
so
how do like who's gonna say if floyd
mayweather beats uh logan paul well
there's like details in there of how
they're going to decide
and then there's what's called trusted
like there's trusted oracles or whatever
yeah yeah yeah there's a group there's a
decentralized group of people who will
all submit their answer what happened
yes or no
and once there's a consensus like if
there is consensus then the bet finishes
it closes
and if there wasn't consensus like you
know uh whatever
is new york city fully reopened by july
1 that's something to me where i'm
curious i don't know how they're going
to resolve that like
fully open it says it needs bars
restaurants blah blah blah blah
but like what if there's some gray area
i don't know how they resolve these bets
in that case
but i find it really fun to like i think
if you look in this podcast by now you
know i'm
kind of a gambler i find this to be a
fun
uh way to gamble on things that you know
you're betting are gonna happen and so
i put 5k into this thing and i started
betting on different bets and i'm having
a blast and so i'm going to keep doing
it
i i i think this is going to be quite
large um
like i want to bet for the saturday
saturday night live thing it said
will elon musk mention dogecoin on
saturday night live
and uh yes was paying out at like 94
cents but i was like i'm pretty sure
he's going to do it
and so i bet yes and so i made i bet 250
bucks and i made 330
or something like that so i made like a
profit of uh i don't know i
forgot it was like 80 bucks or something
like that on the bet dude this is
badass um so how did you find this uh
people learned crypto talk about this
thing i've
i've heard the name before i've been to
it before but this was the first time i
actually started betting on it
like you on twitter they talk about it
yeah i don't even know man i'm just like
so
knee-deep in the crypto world i don't
even know when i hear about things maybe
it's twitter maybe it's a friend i have
no idea oh they just raised money
yeah they've raised money they're
they're kind of well they're like a
well-considered brand i think
um which is kind of weird because this
thing like if you go to the website how
it works and stuff is like pretty skimpy
they don't really do like for a for a
financial betting website you would
expect them to have like
way more like legalese and fine prints
and everything
and they really don't it's very like
very bare bones uh but but yeah it's
pretty cool it's like
a las vegas betting system built on top
of yeah this is direct
ethereum right so if you wonder what's
the value of something like ethereum is
it just speculation like no
people are building essentially casinos
on top of ethereum right
uh outside of the financial system it's
pretty cool do you want to do for the
next episode
do you want to do the first segment
on a how-to we can do because i i think
i've got good research methods and i
could explain mine
but would you be interested in
explaining do you have a particular way
that you find
because i mean i get anything that i a
lot of stuff that i've invested in or
that i invest time or just like
curiosity into i learn from you do you
want to share
how you do that or is that not even a
shareable thing well i have an idea of
something i could share when you started
talking
but uh my brain started to think about
that which is
how to win inside a big company as an
entrepreneur
how to like make a mark inside a big
company so
i've done a couple things since joining
twitch
that i think allowed me to
i just like didn't do the rat race and
instead i made i did i just put a little
effort into these like four or five
other things
that nobody else in the company does and
because of that i got like
an outsized reward i basically um
[Music]
like i made a name for myself in a good
way
you know by doing x y and z and so like
if you're somebody who's in a big
company
and you're like well i'm just i'm just
at this point i'm just another fish in
the sea
or you know i want to get promoted but
i'm like i have to climb this ladder the
way it's currently constructed
my answer is no you don't uh there is a
way to be
like interesting inside a big company
and do a few interesting things
that will let you leave a larger
footprint than just your
job if you do it the way everybody else
who has your same job title in your
company will let you do
and so i'd like to share some of those
things the how-to
how i made my mark inside a big company
and uh
i'd like to share that you know for
others to do in their company
so uh how to i don't know we're gonna
call it how to succeed in a huge company
as an entrepreneur
how to um what i wanna do is like how
how
the how we do research and then maybe a
third one that i want to learn from you
is how do you
manage this small team of people
and because you have like a personal
crew
and like what do you pay them and what
the cost and what's the
roi and things like that that is
something that i would love to learn
from you
yeah i'm down to do that one as well um
and so yeah some people have asked me
about that
so yeah we can we can do that one i
think more people want to know so i
think
people want to know that one and there's
a lot of people who listen to this
that have a job and um they're not like
ready to go quit their job and start a
company they don't
want to tweet out you want to tweet out
those three ideas and or i i can do it
and we'll see what the people say
yeah let's do it i think we should do
all three just in one order we'll do
we'll we'll do one
each time it's okay uh june
3rd did i say i think i said june 3rd to
you we're doing sean and i are doing a
meetup
uh well i guess it's trends and the
hustle and shaun and i
whoever's doing it we're gonna be there
we're gonna host
an interview uh i think with like we
could do our thing
in front of everyone and then also noah
kagan will be there do you know noah i
never met him in person just on the pod
so he'll be there we're going to do it
at his office so he's been kind enough
to let us have his office
uh so you can go to mfn mike my first
million m
f m pod dot com and enter your email
and you'll get notified when that's
being released like the uh
we're going to talk about your town yeah
when we come to you like you're working
with austin yeah we're going to start
with austin that's on june 3rd
it's uh it's likely i'm almost positive
it's completely free
and we'll have room for small 50 people
and then
we haven't settled on this yet but not
the day after but likely the day after
we might go to miami um we haven't
we got to lock that in if you have an
office that could host
100 let's lock it in what are we waiting
for let's lock it in it's done
we haven't we haven't found the venue
but the decision is done yeah like i'll
i'll i'll plan to go but we don't have a
place to be
so we'll figure it out if you want to
host us
and basically if you want to provide
light drinks and light food and you want
to have 50 to 100 people
tell us it's gonna be in the evening
it's gonna be like a seven o'clock thing
maybe 500 people
mayor suarez if you are listening to
this
hey we've traded a couple dms hey you
know i've been seeing you talking to my
friends let's do this
i think we could get 100 or 500 people
i just don't know if i personally would
want to would you want to
like riff in front of 500 people oh yeah
if i'm gonna do 100 why not 500
it doesn't make any difference to me
well i don't even want to do 100 but
let alone 500. uh but yeah whatever i'll
go with the flow
but we need a place so if you want to
host us you can and
i've got a couple other updates so we're
going to talk we got sean
actually did most of the research for
this one we got a ton of cool ideas but
do you want an update on some podcast
stuff
so you might be working with our team
okay so
uh in 3-1 so what was that march march
we did 338
000 downloads in april we did 436 000
downloads so
uh that's a 30 game about in may
it's tracking towards around 520 000
which is another
20 20 increase i think we can keep going
and i want to tell you what i think is
is causing all this
the first is
the biology episode so guests
typically we have found don't work that
well but a really
big name guest or someone that has a
cult following
like a tie or biology um that works
who's ty lopez oh tai lopez okay gotcha
uh when we did that one because he's
like cult following
and a cult unfollowing he's got both
yeah
yeah so that that worked so the
biology's episode is probably gonna be
the most listened
one ever um so that worked out
how much more is it than the usual is
like 20 more 50
more than a typical episode it got to 30
like in the first week typically our
episodes get to 30 000 over like
two months gotcha okay so it it did that
in like a week or whenever it was when
did it get released a week
days five days wednesday i talked to him
on the phone and he said yeah
a good episode i shared it so hopefully
that helps
and then uh he's down to share more but
we only tweeted out i think one clip
from it so he's down to share more clips
and he liked the
animation he was like oh like looks like
production value's going up
i was like sweet yes it is yeah uh
so that worked out well and then do you
want to announce what's working really
well is how to's
so any time a title is called how to
build a paid community
how to build paid events how to whatever
we've done
those rank the highest no matter what or
not no matter what but more often than
not so like in our top 10 most
downloaded stuff
it's either an interview with a huge a
well-known person
um which like an andrew would be a
well-known person or a how-to
blank so we have to do some more almost
like
they don't care about us and our great
ideas they care about themselves
learning something and being able to do
something they want to do
i think that's exactly what it is and
then it's ourselves peppered in there we
are the spice but
the meat is the how-to right and then
finally i got a last update um we're
running some ads on
do you know this thing called the
billionaire investors podcast
what's it called it's like a famous
thing is it we study billionaires is it
that one yeah i love that podcast if
you're looking to do it
yeah so we're running an ad on their net
on their network on that podcast i think
uh we bought it last week i think it's
gonna go live this week
then so there's two types of podcast
advertising that i'm learning about the
one
is what we do is people advertise now
hubspot advertises on our podcast
and people go to hubspot.com mfm
whatever
the other one is podcast platform so
like overcast have you heard of
overcast yeah like these clients these
apps you can use to listen to podcasts
yes and on those clients those uh users
click subscribe
and the strategy that i'm doing is what
we're doing is we are going towards
niche ones because those niche ones
typically have a far loyal following
and you could get low cost per click to
download and subscribe
and it makes sense because those people
if you are
you got to be a real podcast junkie to
go get like a new podcast app because it
has these extra five features about
podcasts so it's actually a really good
audience
that's probably really cheap because
nobody else really goes for them so i i
like the strategy a lot
and they're like they're techie they're
like tech they're early doctors
yeah and so we're running ads currently
on cast box
i've never even heard of them but it
looks cool and then overcast and so
those are some of the updates uh it's
going well okay what about the
so the ad on the we study billionaires
podcast what is it because i'm always
like
if i'm listening to a podcast what's
actually going to make me
go subscribe one is a guy comes on or a
girl comes on and they're a guest
like this happened with elaine elaine
came on our podcast she did ideas
and she said it was like i don't know
one of her biggest uh her newsletter got
like a huge spike in subscribers like
her next email send was
welcome all my new subscribers this is
amazing and she said she got you know
thousands of new subscribers from her
appearance on the pod which is great
and so that one makes sense because if i
go and guest on somebody's podcast
you listen to it for 45 minutes or an
hour because that's your favorite
podcast or that's what you listen to
regularly
and you might be like oh that guess was
cool they said they have a pod i'll go
check it out
i like that method and i'm i've said it
i got to do this i still have to go do
it which is
i want to go guest on as many podcasts
as i can that would be part my
contribution to this growth strategy
but this ad is a little bit different
it's just like a 30 second
sound clip what are we saying in that 30
second sound clip that's going to make
somebody want to subscribe
unfortunately it's not a clip i think
it's going to be stig the main guy
reading but frankly i don't know we just
closed the deal on friday
okay fair enough uh so i have to figure
it out but
we have our guys so we we got this team
uh henry and dylan
they're making like a height like a
sizzle reel right um and we might be
able to use that
but i don't know but i agree with you
like in theory i agree with you i just
don't know what's
what's available at the moment and we're
doing some other stuff to make it easier
to follow
so i'm emailing i've grown my email list
and this year
from zero to twenty six thousand
subscribers now
and at twenty six thousand i just sent
it out the first time last week
so just uh it's uh just seanpuri.com so
if you go subscribe there you get all my
emails but one of the weekly emails i
send now
is a podcast recap so if you don't have
time or you
listen to the pod while you're on the go
i basically take the best three bits
from that lat from the last uh the last
week of episodes and i say
this was the best idea this was kind of
the second most interesting idea here
was the third one
and so sent that out for the first time
and i think that will also make it
easier for people to like
follow along and if you were kind of on
the fence or you were
you're in and out you listen sometimes
you don't listen other times i think
that'll keep you on the hook
because and then i copied your email
like
from sean and i sent it to like 30 000
hustle people who clicked on a
my first million link in the past like
two weeks and we're actually gonna
increase that so it's like 100 000
people and my takeaway so far is
it actually might be good for the user
but shitty for our numbers
because you just get the information
without having to listen which kind of
sucks that that like has to be the case
yeah i thought about that but i don't
think that's actually how the world
works i think if you keep giving people
value
in every form that they want it short
form text long form
clips on twitter clips on youtube video
on youtube podcast audio
if you just keep giving people value
they will learn that
oh and whenever i want ideas whenever i
want to feel that
my wheels turning if i want to get that
juice that energy
um shawn and sam are the place to go to
get it and our
best raw the raw source the real
deal is in the podcast and so i
think over time those clips
they just bring people who are on the
fringes closer to the core
i hope that's the case and i'm betting
that's the case i'm putting my money on
that but
yeah yeah but it's a fear i and and i
want to bring this back to one thing
which is a lot of times we talk about
this inside stuff and hopefully it's not
like a circle jerk like oh we're awesome
yada yada
uh i'm revealing this because a lot of
people people like this i like it when i
hear other people say the numbers
but also i want to point that
i think we're doing really good but i
actually don't think
that we are good i think persistence is
good
and the reason why this is working is
because
persistence works quite well so we're
actually on we're
close to episode 200. we've been doing
this for uh
is it going to be two years two years
two years maybe in september or
august july something like that july and
i would say that we miss i i get sick
sometimes i miss stuff sean will miss
stuff because he had
a baby but we're pretty much always on
and at worst we're mostly at least
good uh like we're like it's typically
always at least
okay sometimes it sucks sometimes it's
really good
mostly it's okay and like
sorry mostly it's good i would say but
that consistency
is actually really important and we're
going to appsumo um
and i guess now in three weeks and
there's a great story
that noah told me or and basically no
kagan runs this company called appsumo
um it's a it's a weekly email where you
get deals on software
this year they're going to do 100
million in gross revenue
of which like 50 50 million is their
revenue it's a great business it's 10
years old
and he was like you know i realized
something that
this business that we're running it's
done really well but it didn't do well
at first
but everyone wants to know like why is
this doing so well and he goes
i really just put in 40 hours a week but
i just did it for
10 years and it has finally started to
pay off and turn out
and done really well and it's just like
it's just a job and i just but i do it
all the time and i treat it like a job
and that has paid dividends
and i think that more people who listen
to us
could kick ass a lot harder if they
treated their side hustle like a job
yeah i i would uh i agree with you
persistence is great the one thing um
that this reminds me of is
i got some advice from the ceo of twitch
emmett and um we so so when i got
acquired
uh when our team got acquired our
company got acquired we were put on a
special project
inside twitch and it was kind of like
one of the like
uh most people at twitch are working on
something that already exists hey this
you know people already use us
we're already the category leader you've
got to make it better make it more
profitable make it smoother make it
whatever it's more like maintaining and
improving
an existing winner and we were put on
this little
we're on the edge of the island and
we're the only team in the company
basically or
one or one of three teams that was
working on something that where we
weren't the winner wasn't proven
and so we uh it was considered like a
kind of a top priority so we did this
thing
uh every week the top my team would
present to the ceo the ceo and the chief
product officer
we had an hour with them every week and
in a big company you don't really get an
hour with those three people
every week that's like a very expensive
meeting as they say
and um because it was important and i
used to
go in and i would try to basically every
i feel like every two weeks i was
pulling a
a rabbit out of my hat trying to be like
and here's the new genius tactic that
we're gonna do and
this one is gonna be the one that works
and like
some of them did make an impact but
emmett had this observation where
he was like you know i feel like you um
have a lot of good ideas
and then every month we're we're
like sort of like on a weekly or monthly
basis when we sit here
it's always like yeah it's good but it's
not as good as we want it to be we're
still like
we're so small we want to be so huge um
and he's like you're impatient with the
results
and so i so i change one thing at the
top of every
um every update that you have to bring
in a memo
at the top of every memo um i was the
only person in the company that was
doing this everybody else their memo
goes straight into like
here's the weekly update here's how it's
going here's what here's what
we're doing next at the top i wrote in
bold
impatience with action patience with
results
i said that's our team motto i'm putting
it up here mostly for myself to remember
impatience with action that's what
impatience is good is when it's
you're being impatient by taking action
but impatience is bad when you're
impatient about results so i'm putting
at the top of this paper every
week
so we're all going to see it so that was
cool then the second
the second lesson came like six months
later nine months later when he was like
by the way you guys notice like we got
the results like
it's actually coming to fruition now and
if we look back
we can't say which one thing we did was
like
the big growth mover and he goes because
there's this uh phrase that i think
andreessen horowitz uses which is
or they made it more popular i guess i
don't know if they invented it but ben
horowitz has it in his book which is
there's no silver bullet there's only
lead bullets
and this is about this is basically
what that means is there's no silver
bullet strategy there's no one thing
you're gonna go do
that's just gonna magically like make
everything okay
make everything work um the only growth
strategy that
truly works over time is a
many lead bullet strategy which means
you fire you do a bunch of things
and you keep firing keep firing keep
firing until the you know
the thing falls over and finally finally
you break through and so i would say
this is a good and so that became the
second motto which is
remember only lead bullets and so that
that was those were the top of
every weekly update was those two that's
pretty good to catch myself
because i'm good but my what's my leak
my leak was
impatience my leak was looking for the
genius tactics
when all it took was lead bullets and
patience
and uh and so you know if you take away
one thing you know us talking about our
growth numbers
i think some people will like it because
they like hearing the actual numbers
it's great when somebody's like
transparent about things
cool we're at over half a million
downloads this month like monthly now
and we're trying to get to a million
some people will be like why do they
talk about their podcast number so much
but i hope the takeaway is forget about
how our podcast is growing that's
probably irrelevant to you
but you probably have a project you're
trying to grow and hearing how sam
thinks and talks about how he's growing
this podcast is gonna be
beneficial for how you do it okay how to
grow a thing
uh yeah back to our how to's i think
that um
and we'll move on but the last the
phrase that i've been thinking about
a lot lately is people overestimate
what they can accomplish in a year but
they underestimate what they can
accomplish in 10 years and decades
right absolutely and and that's kind of
an example here like we've been
frustrated on some month-to-month basis
or a week-to-week basis but like
it's kind of cool seeing these numbers
uh like really start pale
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
what i want to i put my all in it like
no days off
on the road let's travel never looking
back